KAPUR.
>> Reporter: THIS IS HOW EASY HE
MADE IT LOOK TO CREATE HISTORY.
15-YEAR-OLD PRANAV SCORED 18
RUNS IN AN INTERSCHOOL MATCH.
THAT'S A REALLY BIG DEAL IN
CRICKET.
THEN CAME ANOTHER 100, AND
ANOTHER UNTIL HE MADE A WHOPPING
1009 RUNS.
THAT'S A WORLD RECORD -- NOT
JUST FOR SCHOOL CRICKET BUT ANY
FORM OF PROFESSIONAL CRICKET.
NO ONE HAS EVER COME CLOSE TO A
THOUSAND RUNS.
HOW DOES IT FEEL?
>> I'M VERY TIRED.
I'M FEELING HAPPY.
>> Reporter: TIRED 23R
RELENTLESS MEDIA INTERVIEWS AND
THE HERE IS EXHAUSTION OF SO
MANY.
327 TO BE PRECISE.
YOU'RE A SKINNY GUY, WHERE DO
YOU GET THIS ENERGY FROM?
>> I'M SKINNY BUT FOR THIS
AMOUNT OF STRENGTH, I'M NOT
DOING ANY SPECIAL WORK, NO GYM,
NO WEIGHTS, I REALLY.
>> REALLY.
>> Reporter: HE COMES FROM A
MODEST BACKGROUND.
HIS FATHER DRIVES AN AUTO
RICKSHAW AND THEY LIVE IN A TINY
HOME IN A SLUM.
HIS 1009 HAS PROVED THAT
EVERYONE'S EQUAL, HIS FATHER
SAYS.
THIS IS THE MAGIC OF CRICKET.
WHILE WE WERE FILMING, HE
RECEIVED A SURPRISE VISITOR
CARRYING A SURPRISE GIFT -- A
CRICKET BAT FROM HIS HERO AND
CRICKET LEGEND.
>> SEEING THAT BAT, SUCH A BIG
PLAYER SENDING THAT BAT, IT'S A
BIG ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR ME.
>> Reporter: THE WHOLE HOUSE IS
FULL OF FLOURS.
>> BECAUSE OF MY SON.
>> Reporter: HIS MOTHER IS
EXCITED BUT OVERWHELMED.
"I WANT HIM TO BE A GOOD
CRICKETER.
HE SHOULD RISE HIGH BUT KEEP HIS
FEET FIRMLY PLANTED ON THE
GROUND.
THAT'S WHAT I PRAY FOR" SHE
SAYS.
THERE'S A VERY GOOD REASON FANS
AND THE MEDIA TAKE SUCH A KEEN
INTEREST IN MUMBAI'S INTERSCHOOL
CRICKET MATCHES.
THEY'VE PRODUCED CRICKETERS WHO
HAVE GONE ON TO BECOME THE BEST
PLAYERS IN THE WORLD.
THEY ALL BEGAN THEIR CAREERS AS
TEENAGED BOYS PLAYING
INTERSCHOOL CRICKET MATCHES
RIGHT